احتجاجات في احد اكبر مصانع هواتف ايفون
بالعالم لم تخلو من صدامات مع رجال الامن
مشاهد ضجه بها وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الصينيه قبل حضرها لاحقا فع عدد من عمال
مصنع فوكسكون اشتكون من ظروفهم الصحيه
بسبب منعهم من مغادره المصنع منذ اسابيع
هي سياسه الحلقه المغلقه التي تتبعها
الصين لمنع تفشي الفايروس والتي تحكم على
افواجا من العمال عدم مغادره المرافق حيث
خطوط الانتاج
اما الوضع في العاصمه الصينيه فلا يختلف
كثيرا صفائح تصديريه لعزل مجمعات سكنيه
باكملها بعد اكتشاف حاله اصابه فيها مع
اغلاق المطاعم والمقاهي والاماكن
الترفيهيه وطوابير طويله لاجراء الفحص
الاجباري يوميا
وعدده الاصابات في الارتفاع على مستوى
البلاد وهو بمتوسط 20,000 حاله يوميا هذا
الاسبوع اي ضعف اجمالي الاصابات الاسبوع
الماضي اجراءات الاغلاق لا تصب في صالح
الاقتصاد الصيني الذي شهيدا كماشا بنسبه
تجاوزت اثنين في المئه خلال نصف الاول من
العام الحالي بسبب سياسه صفر كبد التي
تتبعها الحكومه فهو اليوم في اسوا حالاته
منذ ظهور الفيروس عام 2020 وفق خبراء
منذ نحوي ثلاث سنوات يعيش الصينيون على
وقع الاغلاقات المتكرره فمفهوم التعايش مع
الفيروس هنا لا يعني بالنسبه للحكومه
تخفيف الاجراءات الوقائيه الصارمه الامر
الذي يزيد حاله الاحتقان في الاوساط
الاجتماعي ويثقل كاهل الاقتصاد الصيني
شيماء شويى الجزيره